Hello. I am the queen of Youtube. -Poppy
Damn it!
Ainsley
I'm all out of ideas
It's finally happened
what do I do
What do I do damnit
Make a joke about Jews
Oh Goddamnit you work for them now
Fuck
Goddamn it Ainsley
There must be something I can do
There must be something that no one else has done before
Jacksepticeye has stopped playing happy wheels
He stopped at episode 100,
you could continue his legacy, my apprentice
But happy wheels is the stupidest game on the planet
I am never touching that shit again
But happy wheels is the stupidest game on the planet. I am never touching that shit again.
*Naruto Opening 16*
How's it going bros my name is Pewdiepieee
Welcome to Happy Wheels
*obnoxious screaming*
My name...
Fuck yeah!
...is Pewdiepie!
Get down and I want to...
Germany!
*more screeching*
For the Valhalla!
Ah, my leg!
...of the tenthousands...
Germany for the Germany
Like I'm not anti-semitic, or whatever it's called. Okay, so don't get the wrong idea
Like I'm not anti-Semitic or whatever it's called
okay so don't get the wrong idea
*more screeching*
*autistic screaching*
Why am I playing this, what's the fucking point?
play happy wheels
I mean I love fucking happy wheels
Geez
What? What is this?
"Download on the app store"
Uh
I gotta, I gotta download this right now
Happy Wheels on my phone
We are truly living in the cybernetic future
Arright so Happy Wheels
Where the fuck is it
Happy Bicycle on Crazy Hills
Happy Wheels Adventure 2017
Happy Zombie Wheels
Happy Wheels Unicycle
Happy Bicycle
That's me
That's fucking my fa- that's me
that's my fanart
What the!
Okay
Umm
Let's start, lets-
here we go
Oh shit he can suck himself off
look at that dawg
Ugh
Fuck
Suck my own dick
Jump
Jump!
If only life were this
Fuuck goddamnit
Wow!
These apps are actually way better than playing actual Happy Wheels
*Play Happy Wheels*
I should be playing the real Happy Wheels
The real Happy Wheels is my favorite game of all time
Welcome to Happy Wheels episode 101
Let's look at the best ones this month
Sword Throw!
I love Sword Throw
You take a fucking sword and then you shove it up Timmy's asshole
Is Timmy doing a Satanic sign
No no no no no we can't show that!
Here we go
Here we go Timmy
Was that your name? I forgot
I mean I don't caree
Timmy voice: "But dad I am scared"
That's uh
I don't care ahah
I'm having fun
Oh shit dawg
Ayy we made it
how abou' dahh
HOW about...
goddamn wall
Come on
Why am I doing this
It's so fucking stupid
It's the same levels over
*Play Happy Wheels*
Oh My Gawdddd
It's pogo man vs naked girls
That's.. a little girl.. that's.. arright
PEDOPHELIA THAT'S-THAT WAS WHAT WAS MISSING!
HERE WE GO
*screaming*
That's fine
I've been fucked by worse
Here we go don't hit my ass
What did I say?
*Music*
Arright fo fucks sakee
Ayy
We meet agian
Why is this goddamn fucking level so fucking hard
I don't remember this game being so fucking
GODDAMNIT
Just stay, lay still honey, lay still and trust me
Do you trust me?
Yes
I mean yes
See
NEXT LEVEL
Get in the Box utra, yay!
Yay!
Uhh
Get in the box
This is fucking pissing me off, I fucking hate this piece of shit
I'm a 26 year old
Hey
Heyya
Hey how you doin', uhu, my name a Jeff
There it is
WHY
Arright here we go
Fuck yes
Das right I'm the Happy Wheels King
King, king hail POODIEPIE
Bitch
12 weapons
*Play Happy Wheels*
So now in Happy Wheels you can press stuff?
*drinks*
*looks up the time*
Oh it's over okay wow
woaah
woohw
dude
duudee
Harpoon dodge 2
b0ss
Okay let's do the Harpoon Dodge
Here we go
I am excited
You gotta click now to star that's a arright level 1
Don't fucking fuck me or I'll... I'll dodge you, I'll dodge you harpoons
I'll doge you
Bring...
Ah, you missed me
You missed me
Oh God
Oh my God I gotta... ahh, fuck, ah sh... okay, stand still
Just... ah okay, duck, duck, duck!
Oh my gawd
oh, oh boy
oh golly
Holy shit that was some matrix shit
*sad music*
Why are we still here
Just to suffer
Everynight...
I can feel my leg
*sad music*
...and my arm...
...and my fingers!
*sad music*
Ainsley
*nazi-salute*
You put a spell on me!
I don't wanna play this shit!
Why?
The answer is simple, the body that I have lost
The comrades i have lost...
...wont stop hurting.
wont stopped hurting....
It's just like they're all still there
You feel it too, don't you?
I'm gonna make them give back our past.
*poods burning Ainsley*
I see now.
I understand.
What I must do:
AHHH!
You're free Ainsley!
We're free!
You don't have to play this game anymore
We don't have to play this game anymore!
The spell is gone!
The spell is gone
Now I can finally play what I want!
good one
We're now looking for brain transplants for Ainsley.
Please, if you have a brain, donate down below.
Any amount would be..eeeehhheeh, any or all your money would be...
..would be..
...sigh... would make such a difference.